you know it's kind of weird after doing
Terminator 1 and 2 and doing True Lies
and all of a sudden you surprise
everyone you want to make a film about
Titanic yeah it's the old
bait-and-switch
uh-huh you know this confuses everyone
come out and when you went everyone said
I want to make a film about Titanic you
can imagine they were ecstatic yeah they
were just like that's it and you can
even see the headlines their Titanic
sinks again and all that kind of thing
right film sinks of its own weight film
is a disaster bah bah you know you can
headlines write themselves and it's kind
of a drag when like people start going
it's a 200 million dollar feel they're
almost rooting for it to fail so what
they think like originally the budget
was gonna be what a hundred million or
something yeah we told him a hundred and
twenty and that's what we thought it was
gonna cost him you weren't Ali weren't
lying to him you know yeah that's it no
in fact that's why I wound up giving
them back my all my money because I said
guys I don't want you to think we lied
to you just can get you to make this
movie right so in other words like they
came to you made the deal and you said
hey you get a couple of million just for
making the movie right and you said to
him halfway through the shooting or
something hey here's the money back yeah
exactly how many years have you devote
I'm talking about from conception to the
end of this film how many years have you
devoted to this well it was three solid
years pretty much from the time I
finished realized okay and you had the
idea you worked on the script I assume
yeah you you you wrote the script
yourself and then you went ahead and you
shot this thing and you've given back
all rights to this movie yeah you own
nothing of this movie nothing and you
will make zero dollars well I own the
authorship of the film what is that what
does that mean it's you know it depends
on how much money means well I mean how
do you make money off the film don't you
get I don't make money off this film you
will not get a percentage of the gross I
would have if things had gone the way
they were supposed to but you know my
philosophy is I take responsibility the
buck stops here so for three years not
getting paid doesn't disturb you well
I'm not gonna be out on the street
selling pens no I mean you're wealthy
man from Terminator and stuff but I'm
comfortable I wouldn't say wealthy
because really I have this habit of
making movies for companies that then
probably go bankrupt and don't pay you
people put you probably out of your mind
to put on Schwarzenegger in it though
right right he was like an oiled up
loincloth guy everybody was handing the
guy swords right what I'm in right and
nobody I mean here I had a role where he
played it with his clothes on the whole
the whole picture you made his career I
would say don't you think I mean you
took him to another level I think it was
a stepping stone for him that that would
have taken him more steps if he hadn't
done that filming he would have gotten
there I mean you know Arnold so you know
what he's like was there anybody else
who could have played that role did you
think of somebody else for that role I
don't think in retrospect anybody else
would have had
did you write it for him now when did
you determine Ange a word of it when I
cast him when did you determine that
Arnold Schwarzenegger should be the
Terminator Oh Minnie bought lunch I took
him to lunch and he bought but you knew
but you knew but you knew that he should
be the guy no it was one of those things
where Arnold is going on about the
script and I really like this scene ever
how did he see the script did you send
it - I sent it to him you send it to him
right and actually his agent sent it to
him to play the other guy the guy that
Michael Biehn played oh really which is
like 30 pages of dialogue and and and at
that point you know Arnold wasn't ready
for that character and he said that he
just has to put it on little cards and
put it up like on the window yeah right
here's trouble memorizing yeah well you
know the scene in Terminator 2 where
he's going on about how the Russians
launch and all that stuff yeah you're
Skynet come becomes aware a lot of that
was 29 1997 all that stuff he had it all
pasted up on the windshield of the car
all stealth bombers are upgraded with
Cyberdyne computers becoming fully
unmanned how do you get to be the
director how do you do where'd you grow
up I went straight from being a truck
driver to being a film director
president true what happened yeah no
kidding
all you got to do is stand there and say
I'm the director did you go to film
scores no nothing no but what I used to
do is I'd I was working as a truck
driver on the weekends I'd Drive down to
USC L in Los Angeles right I lived in
Orange County at the time a truck driver
yeah I was truck driver I'd Drive down
to USC I'd go in and for the cost of the
xeroxing I would Xerox all these like
doctoral dissertations on optical
printing and film stock film emotions
and all that stuff build up these big
binders of like how everything was I was
like a total gearhead so I gave myself
like a full college education for about
$120 Wow you're saying your whole while
you were truck driver yeah you were just
fascinated with sort of how they did
special effects and that kind of stuff
but it was a hobby for you yeah it was a
hobby you never dreamt of being a
filmmaker oh no I was starting to get
serious about it I've 10 busted a movie
I cousin how old were you at this point
we would be driving 24 25 really I was
married lived in a little house you're a
regular guy I was a regular regular guy
so you're telling me you're driving a
truck how do you make the transition to
be the director of how do you get on a
set and was your first movie Terminator
1 I got I got hired to do
his film Khurana - and they fired me
after ten days and what did you get
hired to do directed directed yeah
piranha - Rana - yes that's absolutely
the best flying piranha film ever made
was it a jars ripoff yeah absolutely